jennifer lopez and ben affleck are
giving their romance a real shot
i'm so excited a source tells et that
the former power couple is hopeful about
their relationship this time around
saying quote j.lo and ben are very much
a couple and have been telling friends
that they're together
when they first reconnected they had to
see if the spark was still there because
it had been a while
it was so now they're both fully in it
i'm just taking it one day at a time
ben and jen previously dated back in
2002 and were even engaged before
calling it quits in 2004. however a
source told et last month that the pair
stayed in contact throughout the years
i think we had chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working
the two recently rekindled their romance
last month even spending time
alone on vacation in yellowstone montana
now our source adds that recently the
couple has talked about the past
and why things didn't work out and now
that they have matured
things have been easy it feels really
good and it's really nice jen is also
very elated and really trusts ben ben is
more traditional and low-key in his
values and jen is into that
she likes that they can go on dates and
have fun she also thinks that ben is
extremely smart and has a lot of great
input and as for the difference between
ben and a-rod
the source says jlo and a-rod were
always investing together
and mixing business with their
relationship and ben is less into that
they are just genuinely enjoying each
other's company and having a great time
staying present in the moment
and enjoying all of the wonderful things
that are happening right now
the source adds that jlo is very
supportive of his career
but is also focused on her own life
which includes her twins
max and emmy she spoke to et about
balancing her career and her twins in
2017.
you know once you have kids it's it's a
whole different world
it's a whole different world you know
you go along as an actress and
or performer in this business and it's a
very me me me business you know what i
mean my career my things what am i going
to do next what are my choices
and when you have kids it becomes not
about you
it becomes about them and what's going
to make them happy and what's going to
make them better and what's going to be
better for them and
and your whole life changes and it's
it's this beautiful freeing kind of
loving feeling
where things get in a way
easier because you know what's important
but also harder because you just don't
want to ever fail them
you